on va souvent que de protéger
l'environnement ça nuit au développement
économique
aujourd'hui on vous propose une entrevue
avec quelqu'un qui voit les choses
autrement
jérôme dupras et bassiste du groupe les
cowboys fringants
c'est aussi un scientifique aguerris
spécialiste de la forêt et de
l'environnement
[Musique]
on est dans une crise mondiale de
l'environnement c'est pas seulement une
crise climatique c'est une crise de la
biodiversité
jamais de trop de disparition des
espèces aussi élevées depuis 65 millions
d'années
l'être humain n'a jamais vécu sur terre
avec une concentration de gaz carbonique
aussi élevé dans la
[Musique]
non
pour jérôme dupras il y a urgence d'agir
urgence de cesser ceux ci
[Musique]
et d'encourager ceux là
planter des arbres c'est une dépense
pour les villes mais si l'investissement
était plus rentable
on le croyait pour le savoir le
chercheur s'est donné une mission
calculer ce que rapporte la nature en
ville notamment les arbres dans une
étude publiée récemment montré que pour
les âmes géré par la ville de montréal
donc les quatre cent mille et quelques
armes
il ya des coûts évités en service public
de plus de 4.5 millions $ annuellement
grâce à un logiciel spécialisé il a pu
mesurer à quel point les arbres montréal
et capte les eaux de ruissellement lors
des fortes pluies
réduisent les îlots de chaleur et filtre
l'air le problème c'est que ses services
ne sont jamais comptabilisés par les
villes des villes au québec sont
dépendantes de 70 à 85 % des taxes
foncières donc ça c'est vraiment un
autoroute et développement vers la
transformation des milieux naturels ou
agricoles vers des milieux développer
donc l'idée c'est d'essayer d'ouvrir un
petit peu nos colonnes de chiffres pour
intégrer les contributions de la nature
en ville dans ses décisions sur
l'aménagement du territoire ont pu faire
d'autant plus que les changements
climatiques ont déjà des impacts réels
sur la santé publique
des impacts que les arbres peuvent aider
à atténuer pendant la canicule la forte
période de canicule du 30 juin au 5
juillet 2018
il ya eu 66 morts sur l'île de montréal
dû au fait de cette cette pression
caniculaire
un arbre mature ça représente le travail
de cinq climatiseurs qui fonctionnerait
à raison de 20 heures par jour
le chercheur en économie écologique
croit d'ailleurs qu'on devrait
considérer la forêt urbaine comme une
infrastructure au même titre que les
routes ou les accus duc une idée c'est
cet enfant sociaux nous rend des
services ont pris un compte de taxes
pour avoir accès à des services
donc quand on parle des armes qui
contrôle des eaux de ruissellement qui
lutte contre les îlots de chaleur
on peut aussi investir comme comme
gestionnaires publics ou même comme
citoyen investir notre budget pour
stimuler néfaste au naturel à notre
service mais cette idée devra encore
faire du chemin à l'échelle du canada
ce sont des milliards de dollars qui
sont consacrés aux infrastructures
traditionnelles chaque année et quelques
millions seulement pour l'acquisition et
la restauration de milieux naturels en
ville
pourtant le temps presse car dans bien
des villes une menace pèse sur la forêt
urbaine à montréal un homme sur cinq
dans le front est
en raison de la grille du frêne on va
perdre la grande majorité ces arbres
donc c'est comme sont amputés un
cinquième de notre forêt urbaine
l'ensemble de ses services qui sont
fournies à la population pour éviter les
erreurs du passé
la clé sera la diversité planté
différentes essences qui rendront la
forêt plus résistantes aux pressions
climatiques et aux espèces invasives
outre les arbres jérôme dupras voit un
potentiel immense à développer ici dans
ses grandes étendues casoni il en existe
68 mille hectares sur le territoire de
la communauté métropolitaine de montréal
cela représente près de 20% de la
superficie totale du gazon qu'il faut
entretenir et qui pourtant n'est pas
très efficace sur le plan écologique
la lutte ou aussi l'autre chaleur par
une zone de gaza ni belle et très peu
performante juste combat team as une
zone où il ya des arbustes donc pas
avoir quinze degrés de différence
ressenti au sol dans une journée d'été
entre un gazon et arbustives ou de
graminées
tendre moins souvent le gazon améliore
sa performance environnementale et
favorise aussi la biodiversité
lorsqu'on coupe le gaz ont fréquemment
on a une zone quasi stérile antenne en
termes d'insectes qu'on y retrouve
alors que si on laisse simplement le gaz
ont poussé au au terme de six semaines
on se retrouve avec de 10 à 15 espèces
d'insectes mais remiser la tondeuse
demandera un changement de mentalité
culturellement c'est très fort en irrite
de cette vision d'une belle banlieue ou
d'un beau grand paquet qui gaze année au
gazon frais tondu frais coupés et l'idée
c'est pas non plus de faire disparaître
sont là on aime aller courir en gazon
vendent aux enfants s'amuser il faut en
garder mais l'idée c'est peut-être dans
un grand parc choisir une zone où on
fume tombe plus régulière pour les
besoins qu'ont en or et dans d'autres où
on laisse ce gaz ont poussé dans
d'autres on plante quelques arbustes
qu'elle graminées donc comme sont un
espace qui plus hétérogène
le chercheur nous invite d'ailleurs
revoir notre perception des friches les
zones qui abrite une quantité
surprenante de végétaux d'insectes et
d'animaux mais qui sont trop souvent
comme aménagement du territoire ou même
comme citoyen on valorise beaucoup d
espace très aménagés ou des espaces
naturels sur mature donc on aime un bon
boisé une belle forêt où on aime une
cour qui est qui et bien tondue mais
entre les deux on n'aime pas beaucoup
ces espaces de transition ce qui fait
que dans des milieux urbains
interurbains des des ondes
métropolitaine y en a très peu
pourtant ces zones sont précieuses pour
de nombreux animaux au statut précaire
comme le papillon monarque la couleuvre
brune ou l'hirondelle rustique ces
terrains vagues comme on les appelle
parfois leur servent d'habitat et ces
espaces ne font l'objet d'aucune
protection
un peu comme les bars et à une autre
époque il ya 20 30 à 40 ans les milieux
humides c'est des milieux très peu
valorisé on comprenait pas que c'était
des milieux qui pourraient prôner les
inondations qui était
des habitants pour la biodiversité dont
ce qu'on a fait on les a transformés
comme les autres années et aujourd'hui
on s'en mord les doigts parce qu'il ne
reste très peu de milieux humides faut
faire des lois sur la protection de son
donc l'idée ce serait de voir aussi
c'est frêche l'homme dans une
perspective de deux contributeurs à la
biodiversité locale et des hommes
tu devrais être valorisée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le chercheur est clair nous sommes tous
les gardiens de la biodiversité et nous
avons en ce sens une responsabilité
envers les générations futures
on a une bombe entre les mains et cette
bombe là oui on va en subir les
conséquences mais c'est nos enfants et
leurs enfants qui vont avoir les plus
grandes conséquences de ça donc on eu un
respect intergénérationnel dont on se
doit d'appliquer dans nos décisions
aujourd'hui ça c'est absolument
primordiale
[Musique]